je suis en choisi de joindre une copie
joyau à 24 heures de la première une
dernière répétition
moi j'accepte ça avec beaucoup
d'enthousiasmé à l'or je suis un certain
stress mais le stress est pas mauvais
des fois ça nous permet de bien de bien
s'ajuster de bien performer
trois mois après le début de la pandémie
les juges de la cour suprême se prépare
à reprendre les audiences loin de leurs
grandes salles de cours
jacques tous installés devant leur
ordinateur
on doit avoir la traduction simultanée
et moi je vous donne assure également
que le public pouvait continuer à avoir
accès aux audiences aussi un semblant de
retour à la normale dans un système
longtemps négligée il faut se rappeler
que même avant cette pandémie même avant
cette crise là le système de justice au
pays au québec au canada
c'était l'enfant pauvre la société
attend ou à raison les gens ont tendance
à regarder l'institution comme étant un
peu archaïque josé qu'en général je
pense que le système de justice demande
un peu plus d'amour dans le sens où
effectivement en est encore à la merci
du papier on est à la merci des vieilles
pratiques et peut-être que l'une des des
rares choses ou éléments positifs qui
vole qui va ressortir de cette crise
épouvantable
c'est justement cette réalisation du
besoin de moderniser le système de
justice mieux financer les tribunaux
amender le code criminel pour le
moderniser et faciliter la tenue des
procès dans un délai raisonnable bayonne
cracked et on ne veut pas parce que moi
je ne veux pas qu'on se retrouve avec
catalogue de dos aussi et qui ont été
reportés qui ne peuvent pas procéder
c'est ça le vrai les vrais défis
présentement à travers le pays et
surtout les procès par jury en matière
criminelle ou par définition 12
personnes doivent se retrouver dans dans
un même espace alors on travaille
beaucoup là dessus pour essayer de
trouver des solutions
tous les procès par jury ont dans le
domaine criminel sont suspendus il faut
que ça reprenne un mandat imposant que
le premier magistrat du pays espère
mener à terme
mais pour l'instant richard wagner se
concentre sur l'audience virtuel de
mardi les juges vont interroger les
avocats - dauger il va y avoir quand
même un certain décorum le déclarant
vous savez ce n'est pas pour les juges
le décorum c'est pour les citoyens c'est
pour les justiciables sait pour quel
justiciable réalise tout ce qui se dit
et ce qui se fait dans une salle de
justice c'est sérieux à part le fait
qu'on soit pas dans salle d'audience
on essaie et on pense qu'on va réussir à
maintenir une audition qui va rassembler
beaucoup à une option traditionnel la
course perles en espérant bientôt
réintégrer son tribunal mais dans un
système de justice
profondément transformé ici daniel
thibault radio canada ottawa